so I wasn't somebody who went to Harvard
in Yale got an internship for the
federal judge wound up in Washington and
kind of wound up in the in the White
House I came from a track of on the
political campaigns and you know at the
end of the day you might have a thousand
people working on a political campaign
but there's about 10 you know maybe less
that are that are really calling the
shots making the decision about how to
play an extremely comp icated game uh
that's that's one of the greatest just
stepping back from all the politics
complicated game it is it is a it is the
greatest non-lethal competition in the
world is the race for the presidency of
the of the United States it's a it's an
intense
nonstop experience and um you know my
experience of of having lived out there
in the country I think definitely
prepared me better for it for those
three campaigns for Camp so so let me
ask so you ever seen a movie Moneyball
with Billy Bean and Brad Pit yeah so
we've had Paul manord here we've had
Roger Stone here we've had a lot of
different kinds of people here to get
perspect we've had Jen Jen yuger from
Young Turks we've had a lot of people
CUO and I ask the people that are in the
space in baseball they finally figured
out that the most important stat for a
hitter is what onbase percentage that's
what matters if you want to you know
sell the audience you got to hit home
runs but if you want to win and go into
playoffs it's on based percentage right
Roger Stone talks about certain it
factor that a person's got to have right
just a couple nights ago we're having
dinner and I'm talking about why some
content creators do very well and we
wrote out a bunch of different names and
we gave all of them grades okay and the
highest grade I think was Rogan had the
highest grade out of everybody and these
are four things we wrote it on number
one is content he can pretty much talk
on almost many different levels of
content right so what is the content
you're providing number two is
entertainment you're entertaining to
listen to number number three is
personality it's an attractive
personality that you have it's not an
annoying obnoxious personality you don't
like and number four is storytelling
you're good at telling stories right now
that's for Content creating in politics
um and then in sports you know I'll talk
to Shaq or Kobe and I'll say what what
matters the most Superstar GM or team
owner to to win a championship is it or
head coach right if you own a is it is
it the owner that makes the team win a
championship because he's committed to a
championship so he spends the money is
it the head coach is it the GM or is it
the Superstar you got to get like a you
know jannis or LeBron or Kobe or MJ
right what is that for winning elections
whether it's Governor or president for
you that's been in the space your entire
life okay you're a killer you're hated
by those who can't stand you because
you're you can get as dirty as anybody
else there was a part that you know I
think in the interview 60 Minutes that
was doing an interview with you guys and
they asked it sounds like you're willing
to get as dirty as possible to make sure
this man doesn't win they're like yeah
absolutely it wasn't like you guys were
hesitating you're not trying to be well
no not re that's not your play your play
you're just like no this is who we are
we want to make sure this guy never wins
and doesn't step another foot in the
white house right okay from your
experience to get somebody to win what
things do you need from The Supporting
Cast and then from the other side what
qualities does the talent the candidate
need to stand a chance at winning so
at the beginning of the Bush
campaign the it's clear that John Carrey
is going to be the nominee and so the
Bush campaign turns on and I had I was
in charge of anything that had to do
with John krey it was kind of the tip of
the spear in the in the campaign and so
as the campaign turns on if we were a
football team our first 10 plays were
three
turnovers personal foul two off off
sides in a delay of game and we get a
call about 10 12 of us and it says beat
the White House after after uh after
work uh you're going to meet the
president up in the residence he wants
to talk to
everybody and we were like oh like
we're getting we're getting fired like a
week into this um and so we go up there
and and Carl Ro is sitting there
president walks in he was in a really
good mood and um you bush is uh bush is
an intense guy um I think you see him on
TV now like you know I look at him like
my dad right he's mellow out a little
bit he spends all the time painting yeah
like but he he was an intense guy and
and he came in and question he ask he
goes who's the most experienced
political consultant in the room and
everyone looks at Rove and he goes it's
me right he goes he goes he goes my
dad's 8084 88 92 campaign he goes
through this whole thing
and he says American presidential
campaign has an accidental genius to it
in that it never ends right in Canada
they have an election they call it right
it's going to be in 90 days or in
Britain 120 days this goes on for years
and what he says
is this is a character test he goes all
my flaws you guys will try to cover them
up mitigate them he goes it never work
never
work you go
because he because you are seen for who
you are now David Axelrod he expressed
this by saying it's like an MRI for the
soul that's what a presidential campaign
is and so Bush at the end of this
meeting goes he goes we're going to win
he goes because John car's an
says this bush says this at the
at the meeting right but I've always had
that frame right it's a character test
so so in the campaign what do you need
you need harmony right as an
organization you need Vision to
communicate to the country uh typically
uh and what will happen again is a frame
and a lens of what we share in common
what unites the American people a vision
for moving the country forward uh with a
recognition that at the end of the
election right we're all living here
together and all of our kids are going
to be living here together so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here